five months after election day there are
still a lot of people who can't believe
donald trump lost
well lots of republicans and there's a
good reason
republicans can't believe trump lost the
election because they worked
so hard to rig it for him and they're
already trying to rig the next one
in fact just yesterday the florida
legislature
passed a law to do just that how did we
end up in a democracy with so many
rigged elections
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
voting is the cornerstone of any
democracy but
currently in the u.s 361 bills have been
introduced in 47
states to restrict access to voting
these days restricting voting
is more popular than tick tock or adding
a why to braden
these voter suppression bills are
designed specifically to curb the ways
that black people
and other likely democrats like city
dwellers and working class people
vote for example right now 33 states are
trying to limit
early voting and absentee voting both of
which are favored by voters on the left
there are also bills designed to
restrict mail-in voting
and to make voting lines longer by
cutting back voting hours and
the number of voting machines and then
while you're waiting in that long-ass
line
they want to make it illegal for anyone
to hand you a snack
that's not a joke the georgia
legislature recently passed
a bill that makes it a misdemeanor to
give food or water to voters waiting in
line
no snacks that's a real life bill that
passed and
i already know one voter who's pissed
about it
all these laws put together are designed
to make voting so
time-consuming that working-class voters
can't afford to do it
but voting shouldn't be difficult and
time-consuming and bogged down by a
bunch of complex rules
what is this a vaccine appointment now
republicans say
they're passing all these laws because
they're concerned about voter fraud but
voter fraud is a fake problems that
republicans made up
you know how i know cause republicans
can't find any
the republicans filed 50 court cases
arguing that voter fraud
cost trump the election and lost all of
them
trump lost 50 court cases that man has
more els than laverne's wardrobe
republicans are out here looking for
voter fraud like some of you are looking
for a single man with a bed frame
honey it don't exist just accept it so
why is it that with zero evidence of
voter fraud republicans are trying so
hard to stop black people
from voting because it's a time-honored
american tradition
let's roll it all the way back oh yeah
it's time for your favorite part of this
comedy show
history class [ __ ] i have 150 years
to cover so keep up
in 1870 the 15th amendment gave black
men the right to vote
and right after that black voter
registration
soared in some places it was 90 so white
people were like what have we done
and they invented jim crow laws these
laws kept black people from voting
until 1965 when civil rights activists
got the voting rights act
passed it had a clause called section 5
that listed the places that had
historically
stopped black people from voting and
said that before those places could make
any new voting laws
they had to get approval from congress
so congress could make sure their new
voting laws weren't as racist as their
old ones
because a place with a history of making
racist voting laws
can't be trusted to make voting laws
just like your friend with the t-shirt
that says
it's wine 30 cannot be trusted to be the
designated driver
and section 5 worked finally voting was
kind of fair
yay but then in 2012 two things happen
the first is this
the second is that for the first time
ever black people voted at a higher rate
than
white people and that's when the modern
voter suppression craze
really started all of a sudden
republicans were like voting is rigged
like when a kid loses a dodgeball and is
like
uh i think the ball is broken so that
year
in a case called shelby versus holder
the supreme court struck down section 5
on the grounds that we didn't need it
anymore because
get this racism was over because
you know if you elect one black
president and 44 white ones that means
racism is fixed
just like if you flip a coin 50 times
and i guess right
one time i'm psychic since that ruling
at least 1688
counties have closed polling places and
every single one of those poll closings
would have been covered under section
five
non-white precincts now have fewer
voting machines and longer lines
they made it illegal for black
organizations to register people to vote
and they purged voter rolls the only way
they could have made it harder for black
people to vote
is if when you registered they made you
name three beatles songs
hey jude and uh i'll just see myself out
all this voter suppression was super
successful so successful that in 2016
this happened but then covet happened
and suddenly people were working to
ensure everyone could vote safely so
in the last election people used early
voting
absentee voting and mail-in voting more
than ever before
and dropbox has got more love than they
did when blockbuster was open
which is why in the 2020 election we had
the highest
voter turnout in a century and which is
why all of a sudden
republicans started freaking out about
voter fraud again because
as we've learned when there's high voter
turnout racists respond by trying to
keep black people from voting
this is just history repeating itself
just like it always has
so that's how we got here to 361 bills
across the country that are designed to
fight voter fraud but you and i won't
fall for that because
you and i both know that voter fraud is
a myth just like that single man with a
bed frame
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you